everybody garyvaynerchuk.com 7eq another
one just keep some whining videos no big
deal business is crushing banners are
exploding happy about that you know just
as happy then clever tweeted about being
happy about what I have instead of but I
don't have and I realize that had such
confusion in the marketplace the amount
of people that said success is the
effort I said don't give a [ __ ] about
what you don't have you know I'm very
driven by gravity and what I have and
I'm driven by the climate not the event
and the amount of people that replied
and said women [ __ ] the Jets like who
cares about buying the chest when she
sat by the Jets I was like wow I didn't
realize it wasn't positioning this phone
yes they want to buy the Jets but what
drives my happiness is the trying to buy
a Jets let me be no confusion for the
entire market if there's ever cohesion
let's settle it right here right now
Nate and everybody else when I bought
the New York Jets
it's hoped to be the worst day of my
professional life because I'm going to
achieve what I wanted to wake up the
next morning yes I guess I'll be
calibrated so now I have to be super
awesome but some level just so everyone
understands what drives me and what
makes me so ridiculously happy is that
the day-to-day grind the hustle the
point to try to buy the Jets is what
makes me happy
not actually buying them the data by DHS
is the worst name
my professional life